this story is both ridiculous and sad
now if you weren't aware louis c.k was
recently in toronto using performing at
the yacht jacks there for a series of
shows and it caused a huge uproar all
over the internet as well as to Canadian
media one headline reads disgraced comic
louis c.k gets a standing ovation in
toronto picture was posted of the club
owner taking a picture with louis c.k
and right below it there's a comment by
a comedian named shanti okay and it
reads Jesus Christ y'all give zero shits
about women you employ Congrats on a fun
week now Sean T if you aren't aware is a
queer comedian she's a trans comedian
out of Toronto it was pretty well known
he followed up by saying you should be
ashamed you will sign so many women in
the future who won't say to save their
jobs but it hurts every single time we
were told that the abuse we incur in
this world is acceptable
every time you book an abuser it stinks
I'm a sexual assault survivor I was
assigned FEMA birth I'm allowed to have
an opinion about your club purposely
hire people who abuse us and then one of
the workers at the club writes when
speaking about abusers people who live
in glass houses shouldn't throw stones
let's open up the discussion to everyone
in the community this man really left to
go get some juice I got some lime juice
because that wood is bitter the next
comment comes from a female comic who's
also part of that safe space scene I can
confirm that these accusations of
knowledge of four or more people who
experienced abuse at the hands of
Shanthi like I did most folks know about
her behavior as a predator and a
gatekeeper she writes another comment an
hour later I'm currently being
threatened to stay quiet trying to
figure out if my legal rights before I
can say anything else now here I'm gonna
give you guys a little bit of context
alright there's a huge scene of social
justice warriors okay who are part of
the comedy scene and you know they're
all about cancelling people and doing
all this other stuff and Shaun T is one
of the spearheads of that she's one of
the pioneers of queer and present danger
that's her scene over there
I'm gonna show you what - Oh number one
stop supporting abusers I think that
should be everybody's number one The
Cribs effect on this is real so you had
the audacity to come after Louie CK for
what he did
meanwhile you got even bigger skeletons
in your own closet remember when we did
that video about safe spaces and the guy
with dreads yes and I told everybody
this was back I think in 2018 I said
listen safe spaces aren't what they're
made out to be no what they often are
are breeding grounds for wolves in
sheep's clothing
and when ends up happening is that these
people right who subscribe to these safe
spaces those who are very vulnerable
amongst us that go to these places their
defenses are so low that a lot of wolves
go in there and it's easy pickings
that's why I prefer to live out in the
real world
I don't need places that are geared only
towards people of color why because the
reality is that there is no space that's
just super safe for me I rather just
live up with my eyes wide open always
watching always attentive all the time
rather than this false sense of safety
that people like to build force that's
why that's that's a bit how Rachel
Dolezal was able to get internship what
do you mean
Josh was able to get into position and
then n double acp where where they
thought she was one of one of theirs
even Rachel Dolezal was better because
he didn't try to prey on the life she
wanted to pass this one so imagine
Rachel Dolezal is actually better
because she's not abusing of anything
Wow and there's a lot of people like
that
I know people personally who are
sexually abused me right and I would see
them on Facebook the next day these
women posting Oh men need to do better
this me too movement hasn't done enough
and I'm just like you should believe her
you know what I never called this girl
out I let it go but I remember just
reading that and being so annoyed and so
angry on my booboo you grabbed my
private parts against my will I told you
no and the very next day you're paraded
Iran as this pioneer of social justice
when I know for a fact that you are a
garbage human being gonna call her out
who that girl
no I'm not getting into that okay yeah
why I'm just asking no I don't want to I
don't want to bring that [ __ ] up
you bet you didn't mention that to me
that it was like yeah it was now you
know who it is
I showed you pictures and I know what it
is yeah yeah okay I know what it is yeah
off the record you still on that wall
no not her you know
Nega yeah why are you laughing on my
paint
I literally just told you my whole story
and you're out here laughing no you know
what this life is about what is it about
this is some [ __ ] up [ __ ] you're gonna
cry about it is what I'm not saying no
that's not what's wrong with you errs
he's the problematic one who the [ __ ] I
don't know why this story pisses me off
it's cuz I've been personally banned
from some safe space rooms in fact one
of the victims of Shanthi is one of the
people who helped get me bent and I said
you know what you guys can have your
safe spaces in fact there's a room here
in Montreal that used to be called
psychic City psychic City okay I
remember again man I said okay it's all
good
a month later got closed down one no why
because the person who owned it turned
out to be a sexual abuser
oh so you see what I'm saying I'm like
oh you know I don't even want to go to
these spaces cuz y'all far more
problematic than I can ever hope to be
Jordan Peterson's somewhere out there be
like clean your room before you try to
change the world psychologically
speaking I think they detest what they
are doing to others and so they were to
me as they're cleansing instead of
dealing with whatever problematic
behavior that they're engaged in I hate
what I'm doing let me preach to the
people and you think that I that there's
like self-loathing in there it's a
mixture of different things it's super
messed up because I'm not for canceling
people I'm not no I'm really not for
canceling but I'm for cancelling an
advocate for canceling people if they
get caught doing something that they're
fighting against cuz that's what you
want to do you should taste your own
medicine boo-boo how does it taste
Buckley's it's nasty but it works you
know your first thing was to stop
supporting abusers well guess what boo
boo honey chicken cherry child honey bun
a bunch we should cancel you and stop
supporting you because that not because
that's what I believe in but apparently
that's what you believe in and if you
come out saying oh listen guys these
charges against me aren't true we should
believe her you see it comes back around
full circle I thought this story just
made me chuckle because I got to see a
whole bunch of comics who I thought were
trash and we were bad human beings
came to light and they had the audacity
to say some stuff to me about my
character just because I had questions
and it turns out they didn't have
questions [ __ ] had actions very
questionable it's questionable action
you know we know it's crazy is that she
was born a female she was assigned
female and she trans she's transitioning
right she identifies as a man I guess
yes she's transitioning perfectly
because you know man or the perpetrator
man or the problem and in your
transition you became the problem I mean
hey you you are doing wonders with that
hey you I think you're taking the
transition a little bit too far you a
man need to do better and I want all the
big media outlets the ones who claim to
be all about the rainbow and all these
inclusivity ideas and CBC Radio CTV all
the ones who've been putting Shante up
all the time as some kind of icon and
role model for us to follow I want you
guys to come out and say something about
this too right you guys want to take the
time to bash louis c.k because he's on a
big platform but what happens when one
of your own is engaged in far more
egregious forms of abuse what are you
guys gonna do everyone wants to be self
righteous but nobody wants to look at
themselves in their own behavior
everybody who wants change somebody
wants to break that's it for today's
video we want to know what are your
thoughts leave it in the comments below
[Music]